My favorite job,
I,
my purpose in life always has been to
avoid work.
And I hear these people saying I work
hard and I pay my taxes,
but you're an asshole.
Uh,
because in my readings,
if I,
if the Bible is correct,
and I'm not a biblical scholar by any
means,
but whatever,
Adam and eve did,
I don't know what it was,
but they did something that apparently
and annoyed the guy that made them and
they got booted and she was sentenced to
bear children in pain in labor,
which I didn't mention that we'll have
to grow up to be teenagers.
And he was sentenced to,
uh,
work in the fields where the skin would
be pardoned by the sun and he's hands
will be torn by the thorns and thistles
of the field and we should earn his pred
by the sweat of his brow.
So that to me is work,
you see.
So I always have,
I didn't do it.
He did.
So that him paid the price.
All my sins,
that's called original sin.
All mine are mine and all my sins are
original.
So I've avoided work all my life.
You see?
So I'm like a,
um,
I'd like it be,
I call from flower to flower.
I go where the nectar is and then we
make life jus that a lot of money.
So whatever.
I'm broadcasting,
I like it when I'm writing,
but I'm broadcasting.
I can't wait to hear what I have to say
when I'm writing.
I thoroughly enjoyed.
It just goes off.
I write in Longhand and just goes on and
on and on.
When I was in the saloon business,
I just would greet people and talk to
them and avoid taxes and getting behind
the bar.
Uh,
what else?
I ran for governor of New York and,
uh,
I thoroughly enjoy campaigning,
at all of that.
Mostly anything to do with the
socializing,
entertaining,
having a chat.
There is nothing like it.
And I'm curious to know what's over the
other side there
because people,
uh,
people don't deal with thing is that
people don't die here.
You see,
in America,
they,
they pass away,
they pass on the leavers,
they've gone no longer with us.
Third piece there with the Lord,
the six feet hundred,
they've kicked the bucket.
And,
uh,
and,
and the other thing is they don't allow
a dying on the,
nobody ever says that they don't evil on
the highway.
They won't allow you to die.
I am said,
no passing to give you a ticket if you
die and die.
I would say I'm more spiritual.
You see,
the way I look upon organized religion,
organized religion,
I'm a,
I was a victim of that too.
You know,
um,
mythology and of cruelty and,
uh,
absurd stuff.
An organized religion has all the facets
of organized crime except the compassion
of organized crime.
They will only break your legs.
What does organized religion we'll send
you to hell forever.
We have to think about all that stuff of
snakes and paradise and even,
you know,
making the connection between why.
Okay.
The,
the guy,
whoever was made these Adam and eve and
makes all of these animals,
all the cows and sheep and pigs and
elephants and rhinoceros and rabbits and
the hare is and moles and octopuses and
salmon and trout
and snakes
and of all the animals that he or she,
whatever creative who brings one into
paradise?
The snake.
No.
You'd think you'd bring a a nice though
to dog or her poodle or something at the
paradise to keep Adam and Eve,
uh,
that company know a bloody snake and
instead of a cat,
maybe we just take the cab would have
been no snake and not alone that,
but a talking snake who said,
how are you eat?
I'm fine,
thank you.
How bout this apple?
Oh really?
You're all,
let me try it.
Oh,
Hey Adam.
This is great apple.
So she hands him the apple and they get
tossed out and he has to go on work.
She has to bear children.
And the snake,
they say he has to crawl on his belly
for all eternity and eat dust.
Now if he was a serpent before,
how did he get wrong?
So the banished him and tossed him out a
center to Ireland and then the,
say Saint Patrick came and vanished all
the snakes from Ireland.
So he might have,
because I think they all came here and
took over the Saint Patrick's Day
parade.
That's my ideal.
Well,
I,
uh,
I am an alcoholic,
as I said,
and um,
and it is a harvard,
we caught a disease,
an explanation,
but not an excuse.
So once I know I'm an alcoholic than it
is by a fountain obligation [inaudible]
to see what I can do about healing
myself.
Now there's no recovery from alcoholism.
It is an incurable disease.
And it also is a disease which tells you
you don't have a disease.
It tells you I am your friends and all
you need at any given time is that it'll
drinky pool to make life good and all of
that.
So then you'd take the little drinky
pool and the next thing you know,
you're consumed about 40 drinky pose and
you're acting like a complete ass or
that you were before you had the drink
depaul.
So,
uh,
I discovered that and I said,
I would never,
I would never become an alcoholic like
my father because my father deserted us,
but diseases that don't,
there's no let up.
They get you somewhere or another.
So the alcoholism got me and I ruined my
first marriage with drinking and the
lying,
the seat infidelity and all of that,
the whole bloody thing there was,
I was the complete one,
alienated my first wife.
And although I never,
I was not abusive in the physical sense
in that I did never,
uh,
never a hillsborough hit or like manny,
I'm,
I was lucky the,
I,
I'm not addicted to that kind of thing,
but I also alienated my children from
that marriage.
I'm on good terms with them now.
And,
uh,
I've been married for 45 years to my
second wife.
I've been sober for 25.
And,
uh,
every day I am very grateful that I,
um,
that I don't drink and it's one day at a
time.
That's all there is to it.
And I,
uh,
so I don't have to worry about it.
All I do is okay.
I don't,
I do not have to drink.
And if I feel like it,
I postpone it for 10 minutes.
And I that where I'll find something
else to do in the meantime.
But alcoholism is a dread and offer and
fatal disease.
And I've seen so many horrible and offer
results and consequences of people.
Um,
practicing alcohol ism it's a murder.
I've seen that.
I've seen a lot of suicides,
a lot of strange since set particularly.
You get a lot of thievery and,
and,
and the whole thing is involved.
The lying there,
we were great.
We're liars.
And then a lot of people abuse their
children.
And,
um,
more than hitting,
so many people will abuse the children
sexually as well.
And that is,
uh,
that's that,
that's,
it is a family disease and that's one of
the horrors of,
at when kids are abused sexually in the,
seems to be more of it now than ever.
And I find that,
um,
I find that so sad that that happens.